grammy goes to
brothers osborne
after nine nominations country sibling
duo brothers osbourne have officially
won their first grammy on sunday the
brothers won the award for best country
duo group performance for their track
younger me a song that plays as a letter
to lead vocalist tj osborne who came out
as gay last year and during their
acceptance speech during the
pre-telecast premiere ceremony tj got
emotional while on stage take a look for
those of you who do not know this song
it was written really in response to me
coming out and
and i never thought that i would be able
to do music professionally because of my
sexuality
and i certainly never thought it would
be here on the stage accepting a grammy
after having done something i felt like
was going to be
life-changing and potentially in a very
negative way and here i am tonight
not only accepting this grammy award
with my brother whom of which i love so
much but i'm here with a man that i love
and who loves me back it's just i don't
know what i did be so lucky
thank you thanks for the academy i love
you
does this witty disorder have any
particular significance to you
yeah absolutely i mean in so many ways
you know i think um we john and i have
taken i think a lot of risks in our
career and they sometimes don't always
pay off and we've tried to stick with
who we are and what we do
and this was the validation that you got
for that hard work and the sacrifices
that we made it felt like they were
suddenly weren't all for nothing and i'm
so incredibly grateful for it and i
think on top of that
with the song that we were nominated for
younger me
was a song that my brother and i both
wrote really kind of as a letter to our
younger selves if they could just see
where we are now they would have saved
themselves a lot of heartbreak and
strife and
um and then the the add on to that uh to
be accepting a grammy also just adds to
that story that if i could just tell my
younger self that this would be here
this is where i would be in my life here
on this stage right now i would
certainly not believe it but i would
also be a hell of a lot easier on myself
and our next question last question is
going to be virtual on our monitor
straight ahead all right
keisha from et canada
awesome hi
keisha chante from et canada so the hair
is giving me life
what a transformation
my mom hates it
[Laughter]
but we need to talk about you
acknowledging uh your coming out story
how does it feel to have been embraced
by your country community
yeah i mean i think you know we've seen
this from the past uh award shows with
them that i have felt this incredible
embrace and i think more so feeling it
from the country music fans um you know
where john and i have been in nashville
for a long time we'll have a lot of
friends in the business but
stepping out to the people that that we
don't know who have been there to
support and seeing the crowds when we go
out and perform seeing the people who
just feel a sense of uh uh
freedom to be whoever they are whether
that's just letting their free flag fly
in any way or just just having a room
where there's just no judgment and it's
um
truly just a license to for kind of
liberating and
um that to me going on performing shows
and seeing that happen every night has
been just so incredibly fulfilling